and finally new rules stop making movies
where the hero is a guy who can drive a
car something we let 16-year olds do
what does it say about our psyche that
Hollywood could always count on men to
plunk down 10 bucks to watch another man
make a motor go vroom vroom I recently
caught up with baby driver because the
critics loved it and I had forgotten
that critics are stupid it turns out
it's just one war in a long line of
movies like the transporter series and
fast and furious parts one to infinity
and the new wheel man and dawn in 60
seconds and driven and drive and the
driver and drive angry and ten others
all with the exact same plot when there
is a tough job or even an impossible
mission the key to it is a guy who
possesses the elite mind-blowing skill
of driving
only baby driver can get us out of this
with this great driving in traffic
baby driver - this baby driver is so
it's indispensable to the heist that the
rest of the gang actually hates him
because they think he's too young to be
that great a driver well everybody but
Kevin Spacey thinks he's too young
[Applause]
of course the real world is not so
glamorous baby driver is really over
driver because driving is not that hard
if baby driver is unavailable you know
who else can pick you up after you pull
a job your mom driving is so easy that
cars can now drive themselves in the
same way that vacuum cleaners now vacuum
by themselves but there's never been a
movie about vacuuming there was a movie
called eat my dust but it was about
driving now if baby driver was about an
actual baby who could drive that that
would be impressive but it's not it's
about a man driving a car which isn't
impressive because I'm a man who drives
a car practically every day and rarely
as I'm turning left onto La Cienega do I
think this would make a terrific movie
[Applause]
so I know what you're thinking bill
you've got to make it a big deal about
baby driver true but it gets me to the
larger point hear me out what bothers me
so much about these driving movies is
that it's such a lazy way to be a badass
she should get more of a workout doing
this or even fake doing that when
someone says hey how is that movie about
the really great driver and yet every
day on the street I see some guy in a
muscle car waiting at the light for the
chance to peel out and burn rubber and
tear ass down the street like we should
all be so impressed that he can do this
with his foot but you know who you never
see doing that a woman you probably have
noticed at American lately that there's
something wrong with dudes the recent
stories of sexual harassment are about
many things like misogyny and white
privilege and old-fashioned being a pig
but I'm telling you there is something
toxic about this male laziness if Harvey
Weinstein had made even a minimal effort
join Jenny Craig
shaved listened generally tried to not
look like a Russian cabdriver he could
have attracted women the old-fashioned
way by being rich and not entirely
repulsive you know with all these creeps
there's there's no whining no dining no
game no effort to be charming or witty
just open the bathrobe and say hello to
my little friend and when they get
turned down what is with this epidemic
of I give up you win I'll just
masturbate in front of you
Cosby didn't even want his women
conscious apparently apparently Mark
Halperin's mo was just to rub his
erection against a woman in the office
like he's some kind of horny spider
monkey who dabbles in political analysis
[Laughter]
someone needs to write a book called how
to behave with a woman like you're not
an [ __ ]
with chapters like no one carrying a
resume wants to see your dick and no one
wants to do it in a room where there's a
coffee machine